where you from collider oh you guys have
been very kind to me - there's some
websites that throughout my career from
jean-ralphio now i've always kind of
looked out for me and clatter is one of
them I will continue to be very nice to
you it wasn't you I heard you hate I'd
I've only been in for two years I know I
heard you hate are those pants also from
Target
these are this shirt is from Target I
sure target and then I also have a bunch
of other great shirts from either the
entire like graphic t-shirt rack
I love an old-school to you I collect
vintage t-shirts now for real I have an
old I found this old I'm wasting your
time with us that's all this is what I'm
interested okay great
I have this so I collect vintage
t-shirts have like an old Dick Tracy one
when that came out but one of my
favorites is I have a haunted mansion
Disneyland means I have it Mickey Mouse
going through it that's awesome it's so
beautiful anyway that's your time
Collider I actually do have a question
that is inspired from my billboard I
just saw like 15 minutes ago isn't it
crazy they're just going up yeah no this
one was for a partnership with
jack-in-the-box oh yeah told me that
you're a professional opinion why it's
jack in the box and not sonic no idea i
someone told me that today that there's
like a jack-in-the-box thing and it
might even be my voice being like i love
i have no idea
they put me in a booth i say a bunch of
stuff and then later on see that i'm
like a doll somewhere amazing are you
aware that oh yea hard-hitting questions
i can feel on it yes Sonic's first name
was mr. needle mouse yes because I read
console wars I mean have you read
console wars no console wars is a great
book bleh bleh German named Blake Harris
I believe wrote it but it talks about
that initial thing between Nintendo and
Sega and how Genesis was born but it
goes so deep into Sonic which was great
because Genesis basically launched
relaunched itself with Sonic to make
such a big impact yeah so I didn't know
that I'm wondering an egg man for
Robotnik over there and Robotnik over
here I'm wondering how you think your
performance but differ if the character
was still named mr. Newton
it's a great question and we bring you
in here because you asked them but I
think it would probably be totally
different you want to hear my mister you
know I have a feeling with that was the
voice there would not be a necessity I
think you're right I think it would ruin
the whole film are you also aware of
peacock the the NBC streamer yeah that
has the rights to all these shows I'm
wondering odds in your opinion of a
Parks and Rec reboot or you know so
funny someone asked me that today
they're like hey they're rumors I was
like I nobody told me anything that
would I would be over the moon are you
crazy that would be the most fun ever
and also I think that shows such a
positive show Leslie Knope with such a
positive character that what a fun thing
to have in today's era well all the
stuff is happening to have such a
positive female wonderful character
driven by all these friends around her
it would be awesome I would do that in
whatever Mike sure wants ever for all
time I'll do it so when you so when you
know we'll know when you know yeah right
when I know you guys don't know of
anything and but before I let you go I'm
wondering because you're gonna let me go
well I mean I can stay I live here
I'll work the lights okay well no that's
a union job you came before I let you go
is there anything that you yourself can
do really well really fast oh um I'm
okay too improvising I'm okay at
thinking on my feet I can do an
impression of the woodchuck from Full
House do you remember that doesn't sound
anything like mr. Neil mouth
no but it's a great reference I could do
that but do you know the reference it's
such a specific he has a little
woodchuck and he go well you're wrong
that's his amazing yeah I'm gonna end it
there I don't think there's anything to
be no that is that is the top